-We don't always
have enough time to cover
all of the recent news,
so here with a recap
is one of our writers,
Amber Ruffin,
in a segment we call
"Amber Says What."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey!
You guys,
things have been crazy.
Okay, first of all,
Prince William and Kate
had a baby boy.
And everyone was like, "Whaat?"
Then Kendrick Lamar
became the first rapper ever
to win a Pulitzer Prize
for music.
And I was like, "Whaat?!"
Then trump's lawyer was like,
"I have a secret client."
And I was like, "What?"
[ Laughter ]
Then, he was like,
"It's Sean Hannity!"
And I was like, "What?!"
Then they showed
a picture of Sean Hannity,
and I was like, "Whaat...
happened to him?"
Did he get stung in the neck
by a thousand bees?
Then Starbucks called
the police on two black men
for just sitting there.
And I heard that and was like,
"Whaaaat?"
Then everyone was like,
"We are mad!"
And Starbucks was like,
"We sorry."
Then everyone was like,
"We are still mad."
And Starbucks was like,
"We sorry?"
Then everyone was like,
"We stay mad."
And Starbucks was like,
"We will close 8,000
U.S. stores May 29th
for racial bias training."
And everyone was like,
"...Okay."
[ Laughter ]
Then a white boxer
wearing shorts that said
"America First"
and had a picture
of a border wall on them
went up against a Mexican boxer
and I was like, "Whaaat?"
[ Laughter ]
Then that Mexican boxer
whooped that man so bad.
I was like, "[ Laughs ]"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Que?
Then, the cutest thing happened.
A Golden Retriever service dog
got to march
for its owner's
commencement graduation!
And it wore a cap and gown.
And when it got to the stage,
the Dean shook its paw.
I saw that and was like,
"Woof?!"
Which is dog for "What?!"
[ Laughter ]
Then I found out Trump didn't go
to Barbara Bush's funeral,
and I was like,
"What...a good idea."
But Melania went and she had
the best time with Barack.
They were laughing
and carrying on.
And I was like, "Melania,
what...is that on your face?
I have never seen that before."
[ Laughter ]
Then I heard Beyoncé was going
to perform at Coachella.
And I was like,
"What is Coachella?"
Then someone explained
that it's a festival
in the desert with no seating,
and I was like, "What?
That sounds white."
[ Laughter ]
then they were like,
"You can watch it online!"
So I did, and Beyoncé came out
looking like
literal black r-roy-alty.
[ Laughter ]
She came out looking like
literal black royalty.
Say it three times fast.
You can't.
[ Laughter ]
She came out looking good
is what I'm trying to say,
and I was like, "What?!"
Then she was all like,
"Coachella, where are all
of my strong, beautiful
queens at tonight?"
And I was like, "I'm right here,
alone in my apartment!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
And she had a huge black college
marching band,
and I was like, "Whaat?!"
Then she sang hit
after hit after hit.
And I was like "what"
after "what" after "what."
Then she brought out
her sister Solange,
and I was like, "What?"
Then she brought out
Destiny's Child,
and I was like, "Whaaat?"
Then she brought out Jay-Z,
and I was like,
"This is not about you."
[ Laughter and applause ]
This has been "Amber Says What"
[ Cheers and applause ]